[Music]
lori is in kentucky lori welcome to the
dave ramsey show how can dr john and i
help
hi guys how are you it's so good to be
talking to you you too what's up
thank you so i'm listening to you guys
religiously for several months now
my question today is about justifying
the cost of going to therapy
while wanting to put all of my extra
money toward debt and baby step two
so just a little background i used to go
to therapy after my divorce in 2015
but i haven't been in about three years
and i think it'd be beneficial to start
going again
but um you know my my insurance has a 30
copay per visit if i see a psychologist
that's still like an extra 60 to 120
bucks a month probably
that i'd be spending on that instead of
paying off my debt
what's your household advice um
i make about 72 000 a year okay
and what do you what do you want to
still work on in therapy yeah what do
you want to go to counseling for
sure so um i have some lingering issues
from the divorce still that i see play
out in
my life still today and in relationships
and um
that in anxiety are the main two things
what are they um
trust issues um fear of being left
in a relationship things like that
because i didn't instigate my divorce it
was my ex that did
so those are the two main things off the
top of my head so when somebody can
can articulate here's my challenges
that's
that's one of the cornerstones of what
counseling does for us is it helps us
rake the yard and helps us move all the
soil and the mess out of the way so we
can actually get a
get a snapshot a picture of what's going
on our heart and head you're able just
to articulate it for me
so what would a counselor do and by the
way i'm a huge proponent of going to
therapy
what would a counselor do that a close
friend that you cultivate relationship
with that you're vulnerable with or a
mentor
from your local church or in your
community what would they do for you
that they wouldn't because you've
identified the core issues somebody
somebody left you high and dry totally
hosed you
and now you don't know how to trust them
but more importantly you want to trust
yourself so you articulated that
that sets off all of your internal fear
alarms which is real your disconnection
alarms which is what we've
we've decided to turn into a diagnosis
and make a medical issue called anxiety
right and then you just get anxious for
a while and that makes you depressed so
you've laid all that out for me what is
it what is accounts are going to give
you that a close
vulnerable friend won't
i think i'm probably looking for like
coping mechanisms
um so you know when when these issues
pop up in my daily life like things that
i can do
um to uh re you know kind of retrain my
brain and things like that so i don't
think the way that i think the
negativity that i think
um this seems more beneficial to me from
like a medical professional than
just you know you know chit-chatting
with a friend about it
and getting you know kind of basic
advice from a friend like that i think
that's really like the core of what i'm
looking for
what is your academic training in what's
your degree in um i have a bachelor of
science in communication
okay because you're you're completely
i'm thinking you need to give
therapy yeah yeah you got this so
wrapped up i mean you sound like
somebody does this for a living
right to be fair i have a lot of good
friends in my life who have given me a
lot of good advice it's just not getting
me what i need out of it you know so
that's why i mean
you really are able to articulate it at
an amazing level
right so i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you
two hard things
um and you can disagree with me and you
can say deloney i think you're an idiot
and i'll say hey you got what you paid
for
so the first thing is this you're gonna
have to decide
you're gonna have to look in the mirror
put both hands on your bathroom counter
and you're gonna have to look in the
mirror
and you're gonna have to say lori i'm
moving on
and i'm going to not make anxiety i'm
not going to make trust issues
my identity i'm not going to make that
who i am i am going to
become x and then you're going to have
to get somebody in your life to walk
alongside you
and you can pay for that there's a
million people out there that will take
your money
as dave pointed out you are articulate
you are smart you're gonna have to
decide that this is an identity because
this isn't a task thing this isn't a
series of skills things you know those
skills you know how to
breathe through and you get anxious you
know how to call somebody who's close to
you when
the alarms are going off you know those
things and so if you want to pay
somebody to go do that that's going to
be part two of this question you make 72
000 bucks a year
if you need to invest in your mental
health it's foolish absolutely not to
absolutely here john let me ask you
about this and see if
lori i'm just playing i'm learning here
um
in my mind i worry about um
not lori as much but just in general
sometimes people like
they just want to hang out with a
counselor and they just go year after
year after year after year and don't
seem to get any better
yeah and uh so if i were lori i would
say okay i'm gonna budget 10 sessions
and i'm going to be done right but the
goal being
that i've got the rest of the tools in
my belt to be done right
and i'm going to budget whatever number
session but it's not it's not this is
not
you don't want to do this year after
year after year after year no
right so yeah laura you're going to go
to a a counselor and you're going to say
you're going to go to a psychologist
you're going to find a marriage and
family therapist and you're going to say
here's the deal
i know exactly what it is i know here's
the challenges you got 10 sessions to
walk me out that's exactly right
and what i want is a series of tasks and
skills that you're going to teach me
we're going to we're going to do this
together and then i'm out
and if they say well you know then you
go to the next counselor yeah and
there's a
there's going to be somebody who's
ethnically you have to go back to the
chiropractor every month for the rest of
my life
no thank you you don't you're supposed
to freaking heal me that's right
and healing is both cracking my back and
teaching me the stretches and the
strength building tools
that i don't have to see you again yeah
so the greatest counselor i ever went to
when i sat down her first statement to
me is my goal with you is to work myself
out of a job
there you go and i said that's what i'm
the person i want to see that's what i'm
after and it yeah this is
because the thing is there's always
going to be pain associated with this
past event
it just should be diminishing and it
should be that you have the tools to
work it
and that's what your community should be
for yeah so make sure you're plugged
into a good church as well
and maybe get a lady that's 10 years
older you're 20 years older than you
that's
as articulate and bright as you are to
talk this through with as well
but yeah i think i would go but i would
just put a limit on it and say this is
we're going to be done after this
right and in your own mind and certainly
in the mind of the council
investing in your heart is never a bad
roi exactly
exactly